[Musique]
aux etats unis un cochon est venue au
secours d'un être humain
[Musique]
récemment des chirurgiens de
l'université du maryland ont greffé un
coeur de port génétiquement modifiés un
patient de 57 ans
david bennett souffrait d'arythmie et
d'insuffisance cardiaque
en phase terminale il n'était pas
admissible un coeur humain sa santé
était trop précaire
[Musique]
l'équipe médicale a demandé une
autorisation spéciale aux autorités de
santé américaines pour réaliser cette
greffe expérimental pour des motifs de
compassion
l'opération a duré sept heures
transplanter un humain l'organe d'une
autre espèce c'est ce qu'on appelle une
xénogreffes le coeur d'un port est
semblable à l'atomic mans à celui d'un
humain mais il ya des différences
importantes
à la surface des cellules porcine on
trouve des sucres les anticorps qui
circulent dans le sang humain peuvent
cibler certains de ces sucres et les
attaques et cela provoque le rejet
immédiat de l'organe
pour limiter les risques la société de
biotechnologie revivi corps élève des
porcs génétiquement modifiés
trois gènes sont supprimées de l'adn des
cochons pour empêcher les cellules de
fabriquer des sucres problématique mais
ce n'est pas tout
un autre gène est éliminé pour empêcher
le coeur porcin grossir une fois
transplantées chez l'homme
enfin six gènes humains sont ajoutés au
bagage génétique des cochons il aide le
système immunitaire humain accepté
l'organe animal mais les risques de
rejet ne sont pas éliminés pour autant
le patient du maryland a reçu un
traitement immuno suppresseurs lui aussi
expérimentale en plus des médicaments
anti-rejets habituel
c'est la toute première fois qu'on
greffe un coeur de port génétiquement
modifiés un être humain en moyenne 250
canadiens meurent chaque année en
attendant un organe
[Musique]
avec les cochons génétiquement modifiés
les scientifiques veulent réduire à zéro
les listes d'attentes pour des organes
en plus de leur coeur les pentes
génétiquement modifiés pourraient
fournir leur jeu les fermes dorgal choc
les défenseurs du droit des animaux mais
les défenseurs de ces technologies
avance qu élevé à cochons pour sauver un
humain est plus noble que de le tuer
pour manger sa chair
les xénogreffes sont encore à paris
extrêmement risqué on ne sait pas par
exemple si les choeurs de port seront
assez puissant pour le corps humain des
bipèdes se déplace à la verticale alors
que les ports restent à quatre pattes
les scientifiques continuent de faire
des tests en transplantant des organes
de port chez débat boixe
david bennett est décédé mais il assure
mais que deux mois après la greffe les
chercheurs espèrent avec le temps
obtenir de bien meilleurs résultats
[Musique]